bill maher defense dave chappelle knocks
critics everyone needs to netflix and
chill the f out fox news story netflix
has stood behind the closer which
critics have decried as transphobic over
remarks chappelle made supporting jk
rowling and the gender is based in fact
declaring himself on team turf
trans exclusionary exclusionary radical
feminist
the special has caused a steer among
some netflix employees who have slammed
their employer for back in chappelle
what the f was that the reaction mars
said everyone needs to netflix and uh
chill out really dave's uh
special is offensive but not the show
where the koreans murder each other for
money mar equipped referring to the hit
netflix series squid game mars audience
seemed uh still seemed timid to react to
his remarks on the subject he warned
them well get used to this because we're
going to be talking about it a lot here
we can't be afraid to speak in america
he added freaking bill marvin give your
thoughts
are you kidding me good power love what
bill maher is doing more power to you
buddy this guy's
one of the scariest people in america
today is bill maher to the left yes
here's a guy that's been supportive of
the left they're sitting there saying
bill why aren't you supposed to be on
our side it's like no
you i'm going to talk about like these
things that he's talking about he said
yesterday he said um
he said this a couple months ago in
august i think he said for the longest
time i would always make fun of
conservative comedy i said there's no
place for conservative comedy you can't
do conservative comment he says because
dennis miller who's a great comedian
tried to do comedy making fun of nancy
pelosi for 10 minutes you can't make fun
of nancy pelosi for 10 minutes he says
but sarah palin i can make of it because
nancy pelosi is not dumb sarah palin is
actually his words he called her a [ __ ]
which you know agree or disagree that's
his words but he said today
liberals have gone so far to one side
that if there's ever been a time to have
comic and comedy making fun of the left
today's the season because you're doing
it to yourself this is one of them yeah
your thoughts on this instrument that
works you know as a former comedian i've
hung out with joe rogan before i've hung
out with dave chappelle multiple times
i've never hung out with bill maher but
he's definitely on my like top five
people that i would love to hang with
and learn from these are the these are
the people that i look at as someone who
has identifies as a democrat whatever
you want to call me i love bill maher i
love dave chappelle i love even a rogue
and who's a liberal slash conservative
whatever he is
dave chappelle cannot be canceled
it's not going to happen
uh i did a poll on my instagram story
and i said can dave chappelle be
cancelled 99 said no
i mean
i'm going to put that on twitter okay
it's not going to happen i mean what
person and i think he's getting a lot
like the word transphobic
like
the
phobia phobic it's a fear of something
it's like a hate-mongering theme that's
not what he's doing what i even when i
used to do stand-up and what i love
about dave chappelle it's not racist if
you make fun of everybody yeah equal
opportunity anybody can get it white
people black people latino people trans
people gay people jewish people catholic
people christian people anyone can get
it and that's the point that i think
we're missing just because he's off
limits nothing's off limits just because
he's talking about your people doesn't
mean he hates you no okay if you've ever
seen chappelle show and when he does the
player haters ball he's done entire
skits about just hating on people
it's [ __ ] funny it's humor you're not
going to cancel dave chappelle and 99.9
of people agree with me
nothing in comedy's off limits and if
you're a good comedian you're a chronic
button pusher
you're always getting one of them do you
have any thoughts on this that's just
the biggest thing that stood out to me
was the last point
he's been in yeah bill maher sorry i do
brain fart has been in the news every
week for the past couple weeks on the
statements he's made right and every
time you go watch his audience they have
no idea what to think he's on fire right
now but they and they don't know what to
do they don't know whether to support
him to go again
right they're completely lost this goes
back to the joe manchin thing the
democratic party has no idea what
they're doing right now or where to go
what direction to go when you have
vocal people like this saying listen the
the these people on the left are getting
a little too crazy and i'm a democrat
i've said it before you got to call out
your own side so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you